day rather is international women's day
and we are celebrating women and the
american dream of home ownership yeah
according to recent mortgage data the
valley is a top location for female
homeowners bianca holman joining us live
with a little bit more detail on this
bianca this is pretty neat
yeah some great information that we came
across and also las vegas ranked one of
the top cities for women all around if
you think about it from government
representation social cultural and
economic opportunities like home
ownership so some interesting data
around home ownership here according to
data from national association of
realtors
home ownership rates for women was just
over 61 percent in 2019 compared to just
50 percent in 1990 so you can see that
number continuing to grow especially
here in las vegas we spoke with one
recent homeowner catrice johnson who's
from chicago she purchased her first
home here in las vegas in 2020. that was
a great time she says that she's the
first person in her family to own a home
and after renting for several years she
said it's been the best decision she's
made
what made me get
super serious about it was the future
and leaving a legacy for my daughters
a generational wealth for my daughters
and
it's something that
in these uncertain times
you should definitely have under our
belt and so as a mother i like to leave
by example and i thought i'm going to
put the spirit to the side
johnson says that choosing the right
real estate agent made a huge difference
she was able to answer all of her
questions and ease some of her fears and
definitely find the right loan and
financing for her particular situation
and another
perk that johnson mentioned was that she
could pick whatever closet size she
wanted she could put whatever paint she
wanted she didn't have to compromise on
anything so another perk of purchasing
her own home by herself reporting live
bianca holman live local now